قالت وسائل اعلام ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
يعتزم نشر ما سماه مهمه عسكريه مدنيه في
غرب افريقيا تشمل نشر ضباط وجنود في ساحل
العاج وغانا وتوجو وبنين ياتي ذلك
بالتزامن مع جوله لمساعده وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي للشؤون الافريقيه لبحث الاوضاع
في النيجر مع المسؤولين في سبع دول
بالمنطقه بينها الدول التي تشملها مهمه
الاتحاد
الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلالات اعتزام
الاتحاد الاوروبي نشر ما يقول انها مهمه
عسكريه مدنيه في غرب افريقيا في هذا
التوقيت وما طبيعه المهام التي ستتولى
قواته انجازها في اطار هذه
المهمه ما مغزى تزامن القرار الاوروبي مع
جوله مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكي في
عدد من دول المنطقه وما فرص نجاحها في
تحقيق الاهداف المعلنه لجولتها
على اي نحو يمكن ان ينعكس هذا الاهتمام
الغربي المتزايد بمنطقه غرب افريقيا على
مسار انقلاب النيجر وعلى مستقبل الاوضاع
في المنطقه بصوره
عامه
[موسيقى]
بحسب وسائل اعلام المانيه نقلا عن مصادر
في الاتحاد الاوروبي فان فان الاتحاد
يعتزم نشر مهمه عسكريه مدنيه جديده في غرب
افريقيا في الخريف المقبل وان هدفها تنفيذ
تدريب يمهد لنشر عمليات مكافحه الارهاب في
المنطقه واضافت وسائل الاعلام المذكوره ان
المهمه التي ستشمل غانا وتوجو وبنين وكوت
ديفوار تتضمن نشر ضباط وافراد جيش وشرطه
اوروبيين لم يحدد عددهم في تلك الدول التي
يلاحظ انها تحد من الجنوب كلا من بوركينا
فاسو والنيجر وكلتاهما من الدول التي باتت
تناهض المصالح الغربيه بالمنطقه في الفتره
[موسيقى]
الماضيه
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من جنيف الدكتور
حسني عبيدي استاذ العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه
جنف ومن واشنطن السفير ديفيد شن مساعد
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق لشؤون
افريقيا ومن ابوجا صديق جربا شيهو الاستاذ
المساعد في المركز الاوروبي للدراسات
الامنيه والمختص بالشان الافريقي دكتور
حسني ابدا معك ارسال الاتحاد الاوروبي
جنود الى دول افريقيه اربع الا يعتبر ذلك
بحد ذاته لافتا وان كانت المهمه عسكريه
تدريبيه هو امر لافت لكنه كان منتظرا
باعتبار ان الاتحاد الاوروبي منذ فتره وهو
يبرمج ارسال العديد من البعثات العسكريه
والمدنيه كذلك لان لديها طابع مدني وعسكري
هي مهمه تشبه ما وقع بالضبط في مالي ما
يسمى بمهمه اوكوب النيجر ما والاتحاد
الاوروبي اخذ يعني
بطريقه سريعه جدا دروس ما حدث في النيجر
ويريد استنساخ نفس المهمه التي هي اصلا
مجدوله في برنامج السياسه الخارجيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي لهدفين الهدف الاول هو
هو مواصله اعطاء النصح وتدريب القوات
المسلحه في هذه في هذه الدول ضد الجماعات
المسلحه بالاضافه كذلك وهو الهدف الثاني
والهدف الاساسي اعتقد وهو كيف يمكن مجابهه
التوغل الروسي في المنطقه يمكن القول بان
احداث جر هي التي سرعت في ارسال هذه
المهمه التي اعتقد ستكون مهمه متعدده
ويمكن ان يصل عددها الى اكثر من 100 شخص
عندما تتحدث بانها سرعت هذه المهمه هل
يعني بان القلق بلغ بالاوروبي الى حد
ارسال قوات عسكريه مدنيه كما
وصفتها الى هذه
الدول الاتحاد الاتحاد الاوروبي لا يستعمل
كلمه قوات عسكريه مهمه مدنيه عسكريه هم
يحملون صفه المستشارين او المدربين صحيح
هم ينتمون الى القوات العسكريه لكن لا
يمكن تسميتها قوه مسلحه هي تقوم اصلا
بمهمه تدريب القوات المحليه القوات داخل
هذه الدول الافريقيه نظرا لانها فعلا يعني
ما حدث في النيجر هذه الدول الاوروبيه
مستاءه يجب ان لا ننسى بان المانيا دفعت
بالكثير استثمرت اموال مهمه وجعلت من
النيجر نقطه ارتكاز بالاضافه الى فشر
الاسترا
استراتيجيه فرنسا في منطقه الساحل بعد
سقوط النظام السابق هنا اتحول الى السيد
صديق سيد صديق اذا كان هذا الموقف
الاوروبي وموقف المانيا ودول اخرى استثمرت
كما يقول السيد حسني عبيدي في هذه الدول
وخصيصا في النيجر ماذا عن موقف دول غرب
افريقيا من هذه
المهمه كيف تقرا هذه
المهمه
اوكي نعم في تصوري هذه المهمه القادمه من
[موسيقى]
اوروبا الاتحاد الاوروبي لديه وجود قوي في
منطقه الساحل وفي الشرق الاوسط وفي مناطق
اخرى ايضا نتحدث ايضا عن تواجد في بوركينا
فاسو وفي جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى لكن بحسب
الاحداث التي شهدناها فم كان من الضروري
سحب هذه القوات الاوروبيه من مجموعه من
الدول الافريقيه كان هناك مخط لوضع هذه
القوات في مالي
وفي بوركينافاسو ومناط اخرى لكن الان
نعتقد ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يحاول ان يوازن
بين وجوده والصعود الروسي والصيني في
المناطقه الافريقيه بالنسبه
للاتحاد الاوروبي فمنطقه افريقيا ال
الغربيه ومنطقه الساحل وايضا الشرق الاوسط
تلعب دورا اساسيا على الناحيه الجيوسياسيه
والاقتصاديه بالنسبه
للنيجر فهناك طبعا ازمه كبيره والكثير من
المهاجرين من النيجر يذهبون الى اوروبا
واوروبا مهتمه بشكل كبير لمقار الوجود
الروسي والوجود الصيني في المنطقه وايضا
مكافحه موجات الهجره التي تنبثق من النيجر
والمناطق المحيطه به ايضا اعتقد
ان الكثير من الدول الغربيه تعرف تواجدا
قويا لاوروبا وخاصه فرنسا لكن الان هناك
شعور معادي لفرنسا في هذه المناطق بالتالي
على اوروبا ان تعيد النظر في طريقه
التعامل مع هذه الدول كي تكون مستقره ان
تكون القوى سيد صديق او المهمه من الاتحاد
الاوروبي مجتمعا هل يختلف ذلك لدى الشعوب
الافريقيه من ان تكون قوه من دوله محدده
بعينها كفرنسا مثلا
في
تصوري وكاننا فقدنا الاتصال مع السيد صديق
جربه اعود مره جديده للدكتور حسني عبيدي
دكتور حسني استمعت الى ما قاله السيد صديق
جربه بان هذه القوى او المهمه العسكريه
المد انما تحاول ان توازن الوجود الروسي
والصيني في هذه المنطقه ولكن هل هي قادره
على فعل شيء حقيقي على الارض كيف ستغير
هذه المعادله خاصه بانها تنتشر في دول
يعني ليست من الدول التي ينتشر فيها
الارهاب بشكل كبير او حتى من الدول التي
تعاني من الارهاب
اساسا يعني يجب ان نعرف بان للاتحاد
الاوروبي 10 تمثيليات عسكريه مدنيه في
العالم سبعه منها في افريقيا مما يعني ان
لافريقيا مكانه مهمه في الاستراتيجيه
الاوروبيه صحيح ان الاحداث في النيجير
شكلت منعطف في السياسه الفرنسيه والسياسه
الاوروبيه لا يمكن لقوات اوروبيه او تواجد
اوروبي في النهايه ان يعوض التواجد
الفرنسي الذي كان فعلا يعني عندما لديك
قوه با اكثر من 1500 هذا وتكون لديك بعثه
ب 100 شخص او 120 شخص من الصعب جدا تحقيق
الاهداف التي تريدها فرنسا او الاتحاد
الاوروبي لكن ما يهدف ما يريده الاتحاد
الاوروبي هو المحافظ على المكاسب
والحيلوله دون وقوع دول اخرى او مناطق
اخرى تحت سيطره اما تنظيمات تنظيمات مسلحه
ارهابيه او كذلك تحت التاثير الروسي هي في
النهايه تريد اعطاء الانطباع بان الوجود
الاوروبي ليس وجودا استعماريا واذا كانت
هناك شعور العداء لفرنسا فان اوروبا يمكن
تقدم في النهايه وجود مختلف جدا على فرنسا
لكن اتفقي معك لا يمكن بالنهايه ان تقدم
ما يمكن ان تقدمه دول اخرى مثل فرنسا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه طيب اسمع من
السيد ديفيد شن سيد ديفيد الجانب الامريكي
منخرط في الجهود التي تختص
بالنيجر وايضا منخرط الى حد ما في هذه
المنطقه اليوم ما يقوم به الاتحاد
الاوروبي هل يدعم الجهود الامريكيه ام
يتنافس
معها اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده تدعم
خطوات وجهود الاتحاد الاوروبي هذه جهود
تكميليه لبعضها البعض بين الطرفين للتعامل
مع قضيه
الجهاديين هنك قطع في الصوت الولايات
المتحده منخرط في النيجر وكان الانقلاب
هناك قد اثار الكثير من اسئله حول
الانخراطات المستقبليه في النيجر يبدو
الجهود الان تتحرك نحو دول غرب افريقيا
بشكل متصاعد من اجل منع ماح سيناريو الول
الساحل وبالتالي لدينا زياره الى دولتين
في دول غرب افريقيا ودول ودوله في ال
الساحل من قبل مسؤولينا في الاتحاد
الاوروبي والولايات المتحده بتقديرك الم
تتاخر هذه الجهود السيد
ديفيد يعني نحن نتحدث عن عدوى الانقلابات
نحن نتحدث عن سلسله من الانقلابات عن نهج
جديد يعتمد في هذه
الدول نعم الجهود كانت مستمره لسنوات الان
في مناطق
الساحل هنالك جهود ربما جديده الان في دول
غرب افريقيا بامكاننا ان نقول انه ربما قد
تكون هذه الجهود متاخره نوعا ما لكن
الجهود في منطقه الساحل كانت موجوده لوقت
طويل لسوء الحظ هي لم تحقق اهدافها التي
كانت مؤمل وايضا كانت هنالك الكثير من عدم
الوضوح
بانخراط مجموعه فاجنر من المرتزقه بالتالي
كل هذه الجهود كانت نواياها الطيبه وكانت
مواجه تهدف الى مواجهه الجهاد الدوله
الاسلاميه مثلا لكن ان تاتي بالنتائج
المامول علينا ان ننتظر ونرى طيب قبل ما
ينقطع الاتصال مع السيد صديق كنت اسال ان
كانت الشعوب الافريقيه تنظر لمهمه للاتحاد
الافريقي بشكل مختلف عما تنظر اليه دوله
لدوله اوروبيه بعينها ان نشرت قواتها على
اراض
افريقيه نعم دول المنطقه في السابق لديها
مستويات مختلفه من العلاقات مع الدول
الاوروبيه ومع ذلك من الواضح ان الان هناك
شعور مناوئ ومعادي لفرنسا وفرنسا كانت
دائما هي التي تقود مختلف المهمات
الاور لكن الان الاتحاد الاوروبي ادرك
بنهايه المطاف انه لا يمكنه ان يترك
المجال ولا يفسح المجال للروس وصينيين لكي
يملوا ذلك الفراغ ولا يمكنهم ان يعول على
فرنسا لقياده هذا الجهد بنظر الى العداء
الموجود اتجاه فرنسا هناك طبعا سعي جديد
من قبل فرنسا وبالنسبه للشعوب الافريقيه
فلن تكن لديها اي مش
مع تواجد مهم بمختلف الدول الاوروبيه الان
فرنسا عليها ان تاخذ خطوات الى الوراء
وتترك المجال لدول اوروبيه اخرى لكي تصلح
ما تم تكسيره القرار الاوروبي بخصوص اطلاق
مهمه عسكريه مدنيه في غرب افريقيا يتزامن
مع جوله في المنطقه تقوم بها مساعده وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون الافريقيه ماري
كاثرين فيه تستمر اربعه ايام وتشمل غانا
وتشاد وبينين وكوت ديفوار والسنغال وتوجو
اضافه الى نيجيريا التي اعلنت المسؤوله
الامريكيه بعد اجتماعها برئيسها ورئيس
مفوضيه اكواس انها ناقشت معها دعم
الولايات المتحده لجهود نيجيريا واكوا
لاعاده النظام الدستوري في النيجر
بالاضافه الى استعراض خيارات حل الازمه في
النيجر وهنا اعود الى السيد ديفيد شن سيد
ديفيد ده وزير الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون
الافريقيه ما الذي تحمله معها هل هي في
زياره استكشافيه لاراء هذه الدول وخطط هذه
الدول وتوجهاتها ام تحمل خطه بعينها تسعى
الى الى تاييد هذه الدول
لها اعتقد الى حد ما هي جوله استطلاعيه
لتحديد ما الذي هو ممكن في دول غرب
افريقيا والساحل وهي ايضا تزور تشاد وهي
جار ساحلي الى نيجر وايضا سيكون بالتاكيد
هنالك نقاشات ع ما يمكن القيام به في
النيجر مع التشاديين الوضع في النيجر هو
يحرك هذه الامور هذه الجهود من قبل فرنسا
والولايات المتحده اذ ان ما كان فعال بشكل
كبير في من الناحيه العسكريه في النيجر
الولايات المتحده لديها قوات هناك وليس من
الواضح ما الذي سيحظى مثلا للقوات
الفرنسيه حقيقه انها لم لا تزور لن تزور
النيجر هو امر مثير الاهتمام على الرغم من
وجود سفير هناك بالتالي سيكون هنالك
قرارات حما سيتم القيام به في النيجر مع
الاطراف الاخرى طيب سيد ديفيد شن الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ومساعده وزير الخارجيه
ايدت جهود اكواس جهود اكواس قد تصل الى
تدخل عسكري كيف يمكن ان تترجم الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هذا الدعم في حال تدخل
عسكري الولايات المتحده كانت واضحه في
دعمها
للاستمرار الحكم الديمقراطي في النيجر
وايضا واكدت واعاده الرئيس بزوم ل سده
الرئاسه هناك وهذا الوضع الذي عبرت عنه
الاكواس والاكوا اس وانت محقه قالت انها
تحدثت عن التدخل العسكري في النيجير وهذا
امر لم يحدث ولا وليس من الواضح اذا ما
كان سيحدث وكذلك ليس من الواضح ما الذي
ستقوم به الولايات المتحده من اجل ان تدعم
مثل هذا الجهد اعتقدوا انه قد يكون تكون
هذه المهمه صعبه للغايه ومثاليا يجب ان
يكون الح
وليس عسكريا لكن كل ذلك يبقى في طيات
المستقبل سيد حسني عبيدي يعني تقييمك
للجهود الامريكيه ولهذه الجوله التي تقوم
بها مساعده وزير الخارجيه كل الدول التي
تزورها باستثناء تشاد دعمت الاكواس ودعمت
امكانيه التدخل العسكري بالتالي ما الذي
يمكن ان تكون تناقشه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه صحيح انها دعمت الخيار العسكري
لكنها في النهايه برئاسه نيجيريا تقول
بانه يجب ترك الفرصه للحل الدبلوماسي وانا
اعتقد ان التصريحات الاخيره لرئيس نيجيريا
ت تشير الى ذلك اي انه اكثر تحمسا للحل
العسكري عما كان عليه في السابق لكن عموما
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي وصل
الى نفس التقيييم وهو انه الان سياسه
فرنسا في ازمه وحتى المقاربه الفرنسيه
للخروج من هذه الازمه
يعني في في صعوبه كبيره ولذلك الاتحاد
الاوروبي فضل في النهايه ان
يبدا لنقول مبادره جديده تتمثل في مل
الفراخ وتقديم بعثات مدنيه عسكريه لعدم
التفريط في بعض النفوذ والتاثير الذي تحظى
به دول اوروبا التي تساعد عسكريا العديد
من المشاريع الولايات المتحده نفس الشيء
وصلت الى نفس الخيار ونعتقد وجود السفيره
التي كانت موجوده في نفس يوم زياره
الايكواس بالاضافه الى نائبه او مساعده
وزير الخارجيه للشؤون الافريقيه هي
لمحاوله كذلك بحث مدى نجاعه هذا الخيار
الدبلوماسي ما هي الضمانات التي يمكن ان
نطالب بها العسكر وهي تاتي يج الاشاره بعد
كذلك زياره لوزير الخارجيه الجزائري
لواشنطن ولقائه مع بلينكن
وحيث تحدث على قضيه ان الخيار العسكري
سيكون مكلفا جديدا كثيرا بالنسبه للنيجر
وللدول الاخرى فانا اعتقد الازمه وال
المازق الذي تعيش فيه الذي تعيش في فرنسا
في النيجر هو الذي ادى باوروبا وواشنطن
كذلك
بتحريك وتسارع وتيره التحرك الدبلوماسي في
المنطقه طيب تسريع وتيره التحرك كما
وصفتها وهنا اتحول الى سيد صديق يعني
تسريع وتيره التحركات الدبلوماسيه هل يمكن
ان تفتح قوه في جدار الازمه
بتقديرك
سيد صديق اكرر عليك السؤال المساعي
الدبلوماسيه المتزايده في الفتره الاخيره
هل يمكن ان تحقق
شيئا ا ع تصوري بنظر الى الوضع الراهن
فليس هناك حل بديل عن الحل الدبلوماسي
هناك بعض الدول طبعا تضغط باتجاه الحل
العسكري لكنها وصلت الى خلاصه الى ان ليس
هناك بديل عن الحل الدبلوماسي وراينا
التحركات من جانب الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
والاتحاد الاوروبي فهي كلها تسعى للحل
الدبلوماسي وحتى الدول التي هي دمن الكوس
كان تسع تدخل العسكري وهي تندر
بشكل اكثر دقه في الوضع الان هناك توجه
لتدخل لحل الازمه بطريقه دبلوماسيه مجموعه
من الدول في غرب افريقيا فيما يخص خاصه
دول الاكوس ليس هناك اجماع على التدخل
العسكري اذا الاتحاد الاوري الافريقي
بالحراك كان دائما يدعو
لتدخل سلمي لحل هذه الازمه وكان هناك
دائما دعوه لا اطلاق
وساطات وصلت الفكره سيد صديق دعني اسمع من
السيد ديفيد سيد ديفيد يعني في بدايه هذه
الحلقه تحدثتم عن الاسباب التي ادت الى
تزايد الاهتمام الغربي في غرب افريقيا
ولكن كيف يمكن ان يؤثر ذلك على م مستقبل
هذه
المنطقه بشكل مثالي فان الولايات المتحده
ترغب برؤيه بعض التطور في مساله قطع
العلاقات مع القوات الجهاديه والقضاء
عليها مثلا في منطقه الساحل ومالي
وبوركينا فاس وهي الان تهدد ربما اجزاء
اخرى من افريقيا بضمنها حتى اجزاء من غرب
افريقيا بالتالي فان الولايات المتحده
وجهودها تهدف الى عمل مع الافارقه ومع
الاوروبيين من اجل ايقاف هذا الامر
ووضع برامج تدريبيه وجهد دبلوماسي في حتى
الان لم يحدث هذا الامر نجاحات كبيره
وبالتاكيد هنالك بحث لقضايا لاساليب اخرى
من لبرامج اخرى من اجل القضاء على هذا
التهديد شكرا لك ديفيد شن مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق لشؤون افريقيا
وشكر موصول للسيد صديق جربش الاستاذ
المساعد في المركز الاوروبي للدراسات
الامنيه والمختص بالشان الافريقيه
والدكتور حسني عبيدي استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه بجامعه
جناف الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
h